[Music]
hello
let's talk about api program governance
what is governance
and more importantly how would that
apply to your api program
governance is defined as to rule and
control
but in our fast-paced environment where
innovation is key to attaining that
competitive edge
heavyweight ruling can control or slow
down things
and slowing things down progress can be
impeded
governance when applied to the api first
model is a balancing act
we need to manage risk while enabling
speed and agility in order to meet the
consumer's needs
we don't want heavyweight authority
control or regulation
and this is why we call it a little g
finding the balance depends on your
organization
startup versus traditional enterprise
risk appetite versus speed requirement
let's talk about the keys to managing
risk while still maintaining the ability
to meet market needs
the balance comes from an intersection
of four components
first are the key roles within an api
team
second is the structure of the team
focused on the digital initiative
third is the ownership of the api
products
and the fourth and final component are
the simple guidelines and structures
around the platform for ease of adoption
as mentioned in the previous video
around api team composition
it is essential to have an api team
leader who is aligned with both the
business and it
this role is called the api product
owner and it is a key component to
ensuring that the apis built
target a priority business outcome
central team
defines api development standards and
developed apis based on the requirements
from
product project and business unit teams
this model allows for consistency in
development
approach and adherence however this
model lacks the agility that some of the
other models have
a decentralized operating model has the
agility in the speed
but lacks the standards and common
development best practices
this combined with a lack of clear
ownership after the apis are released
showcases how different this model is
compared to that of the centralized
model
so now we arrive at the hybrid model
this model possesses the speed and
agility of the decentralized model
while also maintaining a close adherence
to standards
the downside is that a lot of
coordination is needed when it comes to
the requirements across multiple teams
so who owns which apis ownership of the
apis or the components that make up
those apis is dependent upon the
operating model
for example in a hybrid model the
platform team is responsible for setting
guidelines
standards and the reusable assets
reusable assets are in the form of
shared flows or
shared services that adhere to a common
practice such as security
traffic management or error handling
this frees up the specific
product project and business unit teams
to focus on api supporting their
business objectives
delivery can be much faster when the
teams don't have to worry about the
standards for common assets
reusable assets can be selected from an
a la carte menu
to include in the delivery team's api
product
big g governance is what most companies
end up with
this assumes that the teams are not
trusted to do the right thing and
results in heavy gating
committees like change approval boards
are formed to manually audit any change
that
are pushed to deployed systems
policies and procedures are written into
heavyweight word documents
and teams are split by function as they
are not trusted to work together
little g governance is harder for an
organization to swallow as
responsibility and accountability
is pushed down to where the decision
needs to be made
it provides enough governance to keep
the teams on the right path
but doesn't seek the slow delivery now
let's run through an analogy of a
freeway
while you're on a freeway the direction
is set but can be changed at junctions
guard wells help keep cars on the right
side of the road and traveling safely in
the right direction
lanes are painted to suggest the right
way to drive but can be crossed if
needed
the emphasis here is on keeping the flow
now imagine if big g governance was in
control
every time you needed to accelerate slow
down change
lanes or even change direction someone
else would need to have to review that
decision
and approve it for you now imagine what
that would do to traffic
little g governance provides standards
principles and best practices
teams are trusted and empowered through
tooling and automation
information and documentation is shared
collaboratively
teams are cross-functional to minimize
handoff and communication issues
going back to the freeway analogy little
g governance operates how we think of
freeways today
organizations have hierarchy what tends
to happen
is that we push information to authority
the people at the bottom
have the information but they don't have
the authority to make the decision
this results in bottlenecks and delays
we create systems that channel
information up where a decision is then
taken
and then that information comes back
down again as you can imagine this tends
to take a lot of time
an alternative is pushing authority to
the information
the foundation for this model is making
sure that the people that are closest to
the information
are both technically competent and have
organizational clarity
they understand the priorities and know
what the right thing to do
they are empowered to make the decisions
and as a result they are happier for it
if your organization is truly undergoing
a digital transformation
it is deeper than building a mobile app
or putting some apis on a developer
portal
think about why your company started
this initiative in the first place
if the benefits include reducing costs
and accelerating time to market
then the initiative has to go well
beyond that of just building apis
to achieve those aims imposing a
heavyweight process that encourages
blind compliance
with no room to accelerate delivery will
at best slow
or at worst stop the benefits of the
program
to achieve those aims imposing a
heavyweight process that encourages
blind compliance
with no room to accelerate delivery will
at best slow
or at war stop the benefits of the
program
much of the time governance processes
are imposed top down
and borne out of quick resolutions to
problems encountered
the gates and posts often have
documentation required at each stage
which are slow to produce
and discourage effective communication
between teams
ultimately the focus is on the process
protecting the organization
from the it teams who they don't trust
to do the right thing
this is done so rather than accelerating
business outcomes in a safe manner
so how do we apply this to the api
governance model
if a centralized team have all the
authority then we can't scale
and agility is inhibited we must give
developers publishing or consuming apis
the information and knowledge they need
to publish and use those apis
thank you